comment expliquer cette pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre quelles solutions pour y
remédier et voilà le thème de notre
débat et je vous présente mes invités
anne sophie lcif bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes chef économiste au cabinet de
conseil bdo france jean christophe
romand soir soit bien du président de la
capeb c'est la confédération de
l'artisanat et des petites entreprises
du bâtiment vous représentez plus de 550
mille entreprises et emploie plus de 650
mille salariés les entreprises du
bâtiment c'est dans leur immense
majorité des entreprises mois de moins
de 10 salariés moyenne 20 95 % moins de
10 et 90 7 moines 20 donc le bâtiment
voilà il vous c'est vous en quelque
sorte on peut dire que ça me fait
plaisir c'est michel beaugas bonsoir
bonsoir ouga ouga ce pardon je peux vous
vêtir les deux figures évocation du
sud
secrétaire confédéral de force ouvrière
en charge la politique de l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle de l'assurance
chômage et des retraites en
visioconférence avec nous françois
bergerault qui est co fondateur de
l'atelier des chefs bonsoir merci d'être
là vous êtes également vice président de
croissanceplus et laetitia casta est
resté à mes côté l'éditorialiste
des mardis et jeudis dans sens public je
voudrais qu'on commence par une
explication et peut-être que
l'explication elle tient dans dans ces
chiffres on va faire le constat des
secteurs en tension pour les chiffres
qu'on a trouvé aujourd'hui dans
l'hôtellerie restauration
deux cent trente sept mille emplois
perdus entre février 2002 20 février
2021 le transport routier cherche entre
40 et 50 mille emplois vacants à fournir
dans le btp vous me confirmez vrai on
est à autour de 110 mille emplois
vacants agriculture entre 50000 et 70000
à sophie elle s'y fait ce que la
première explication c'est l'effet qu'au
vide est-ce que effectivement 7 cette
année ses 18 mois si particulier ont
ramené les français à ceux de se poser
cette question le pourquoi pourquoi je
travaille pourquoi je fais ce métier
alors déjà c'est tout à fait un c'est
l'effet qu'au guide c'est déjà des
secteurs qui ont des particularités très
différentes on va dire des secteurs
traditionnels que ça dans l'industrie et
dans les services mhcs c'est des
secteurs où il ya beaucoup plus de cdd
et d'intérim donc d'emplois dit non
stable et donc qui ont été beaucoup plus
impactée par le cos vie parce que j'ai
un appel qui est le chômage partiel
n'hésitez pas à rembourser à 100% et
puis ça dépend des aussi de votre
contrat de travail tant que ce sont des
catégories qui peut qui est censé y ait
des différences mais qui ont eu le plus
de pertes de pouvoir d'achat et de
baisses de salaires donc qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé beaucoup de ces personnes là
dans ces secteurs on veut se sont dit on
va utiliser cette opportunité puisque il
beaucoup balle et restaurants étaient
fermés n'avait plus du tout d'activité
pour faire des formations ou pour
devenir auto entrepreneur
l'année dernière ça qu'on a regardé les
chiffres de créations d'entreprises ont
saisi une explosion c'est quand même
très étonnant alors en pleine crise il a
mis autant de créations d'entreprises
des faillites kadhafi ont déclenché et
donc beaucoup de ces personnes se sont
dit eh bien on va se mettre à notre
compte créer notre propre entreprise
notre activité et puis faire des
formations pour peut-être changer de
secteur c'est aussi des secteurs où les
conditions de travail et des
rémunérations sont assez difficiles donc
forcément lorsqu'il ya eu ce qu vide et
bien il ya eu une réflexion sur le sens
et de se dire c'est peut-être aussi pour
moi l'opportunité de changer de secteur
et michel beaugas c'est aussi le temps
qui a été passé en famille c'est un
élément important de la réflexion des
salariés oui effectivement notamment
pour les salariés dhr con quand même des
horaires atypiques les conditions que
c'est faux c'est le riz restauration
mais obéit pardon c'est vraiment mais
voilà et effectivement quand vous
travaillez tous les soirs jusqu'à tard
quand vous travaillez le samedi et le
dimanche eh bien ces salariés là puisque
les restaurants étaient fermés les
hôtels aussi ou redécouvert une vie de
famille est pour beaucoup et bien
souhaite pouvoir conserver cette vie de
famille est d'ailleurs le patronat l'a
entendu puisque on va rentrer dans des
négociations où effectivement il est
proposé de travailler qu un week-end sur
deux d'avoir des congés supplémentaires
donc voila et le co vide à auxi se
saluent aussi ce bon côté que de pouvoir
montrer du doigt aux employeurs qu'il y
avait des difficultés dans les
conditions on y reviendra évidemment
mais je voudrais entendre tout de suite
françois bergerault dans votre dans vos
restaurants il ya eu ce phénomène c'est
à dire qu'il ya des salariés sont pas
revenus tout simplement
alors oui il ya effectivement des
salariés ils sont pas revenus et puis
reste qu est ce qui est compliqué c'est
que non on a toujours ce qu'on appelle
le turnover donc des gens qui quittent
l'entreprise parce que ce sont des
métiers qu'on fait très souvent gp du
mans pour toutes les contraintes on
vient de nommer on les quitte quand on
commence à avoir une vie de famille pas
tout le monde mais beaucoup et là en
fait on s'est rendu compte que beaucoup
étaient partis à certains étaient partis
et on a beaucoup de mal à les remplacer
et donc on se retrouve vous savez dans
la restauration la période octobre de
ventes d'essence et une très très grosse
période c'est la fin de l'année et on se
retrouve au début de saison avec avec
effectivement des vrais des vrais
problèmes de personne jean christophe
lebon pareil le le constat c'est vrai
que dans le secteur de l'hôtellerie
restauration c'est vertigineux parce que
ces 200 japon le chiffre de cent trente
sept mille de sorcier signes et c'est
que c'est sûr combien d'emplois françois
bergerault ckoi 800 850 mille emplois
c'est combien d'emplois le secteur
minier
en parler puisque nous on n'a pas
détruit dans le pour l'apprenant le coc
vide en a vraiment une perte d'activité
de 2 3 1 - maximum donc ça veut dire
qu'on n'a pas détruit de l'emploi et on
a quand même alors je parlerai plus
particulièrement de la tpe de la petite
entreprise artisanat du bâtiment on n'a
pas licencié on a gardé nos salariés on
a fait l'activité partielle nous ce qui
nous qui nous pèse aujourd'hui c'est
c'est un bien c'était qu'on a beaucoup
d'activités et que le coc vide a aussi
amené le particulier a repensé son sa
vie son habitat la rénovation
énergétique qui est une partie du
secteur fait que l'activité d adapter
l'entreprise artisanale donc le
particulier refait les chantiers chez du
travail chez lui embellie dimensionne
télétravail et donc du coup nous on a
récupéré quasiment l'activité d'avant
crise et même de début 2019 qui était
une gêne très belle année et donc du
coup il nous manque une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre un manque de mandeure qu'on
avait déjà avant
en 2010 neuf là vous pourriez embauché
combien de personnes là on a déjà
embauché en 2021 26000 en salariés dans
les entreprises jusqu'à 10 salariés
maintenant on a le potentiel on me
semble-t-il au moins identique au moins
identique dans le dans la tpe dans les
grands groupes comme vous devez faire
dedans dans le reportage sûrement qu'on
a aussi un potentiel même si l'activité
du neuf et de la construction neuve
attarde un peu à elle à repartir mais
dans la rénovation pur on a deux sur la
capacité de pouvoir encore embaucher et
on a besoin de demandeurs compétentes
qualifiés et d'avoir des gens qui soient
motivés à être présent et à partir d'un
projet de vie et c'est pour ça que je
peux donner du sens à sa vie dans des
zones d'emploi ou du bâtiment et de
l'artisanat en particulier me semblent
intéressantes dans l'avenir à vous êtes
en train de dire si vous étiez dans un
autre secteur venait voir du côté du
bâtiment c'est ça je dis ça négligemment
nous
mais on attend on a de l'avenir on a des
me semble-t-il avec la rénovation
énergétique notamment quelques années de
travaux intéressants en plus j'avais une
question pour vous madame où sont partis
tous ses salariés qui ont déserté ces
secteurs ils sont où sont du côté des
chômeurs ou est-ce que sont dans un
autre secteur d'activité alors ça va
quand on regarde les chiffres beaucoup
donc une partie son auto entrepreneur
est un généraliste ils sont restés dans
les services donc typiquement par
exemple vous étiez serveur dans un
restaurant ou des auto-entrepreneurs
vous allez travailler pour des
plateformes en ligne donc vous allez
être indépendant mais vous restez un
petit peu dans le même secteur
d'activité mais voilà vous avez une
autre une autre fonction une partie qui
est aussi resté au chômage et une partie
qui en formation donc c'est vrai qu'il
est tout un plan formation qui avait été
mis en place par le gouvernement qui a
fonctionné donc là ce sont des gens qui
sont partis pour plusieurs mois et qui
change complètement de secteur et puis
on a aussi qui se disent on va créer une
entreprise dans un secteur qui n'était
pas du tout le nôtre et là aussi on le
voit alors souvent quand même annexe à
la première activité mais quand même en
essayant voilà développer des fois de
l'innovation et c'est surtout en effet
sur internet et s'est développé des
sites des choses de vente en ligne on
voit que la précarité que ces emplois
d'auto entrepreneur
voilà faut toujours faire attention
quand on verra les chiffres de créations
d'entreprises pour garder la création
d'entreprise à deux ans pour voir sa lé
père n est pas juste le chiffre global
c'est comme vous l'aviez dit le grand
problème dans la création d'entreprises
surtout en france on voit chez les
jeunes mais également sur les plus de 55
ans est souvent faute des gens qui sont
au chômage qui ne trouvent pas être
embauchés et donc ils créent leur propre
emploi donc c'est une création
d'entreprise mais ça montre aussi qu'on
a des carences au niveau justement notre
système de formation et recrutement est
alors l'une des infos du jour évidemment
c c'est le taux de chômage de chiffres
du chômage qui a été révélé par l'insee
7,6 pour cent de la population active
niveau le plus bas depuis
2008 et moi j'ai envie de le mettre en
miroir avec
les offres reçues chez pôle emploi 926
me l'offre d'emploi reçues entre juin et
août
1921 et 10 ans donc c'était pendant cet
été évidemment je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
dû voir apparaître un 9 sur ma sur ma
feuille alors moi il ya quand même
quelque chose qui me qui le dépasse et
comment on peut avoir autant d'offres
d'emploi proposées chez pôle emploi et
encore alors selon les chiffres du
bureau international du travail 2
millions 400 mille chômeurs évidemment
c'est plus si on est on agrège si on dit
le halo du chômage comment c'est
possible ça dépasse mon entendement
pardon alors il ya des explications à ce
que ce serait plus simple révolte ou de
chômage oui on aurait une solution voilà
exactement déjà le plein emploi c'est 4
5% donc vrai que là on est à 7 6 mais on
est encore un peu 3 points au-dessus de
ce qu'on serait dans une situation de
plein emploi donc on a quand même encore
du travail les cadres sont en situation
de plein emploi voilà vous avez un
niveau de qualification élevé moins vous
avez de problème donc en effet tant dans
le grand problème de ces de ces trois
points et pourquoi il ya cette
dichotomie c'est la formation le grand
problème c'est que la demande que vous
avez dans ce secteur ne correspond pas
forcément aux personnes qui sont au
chômage et que l'adéquation avec les
formations et le problème que l'on a
souvent en france et que l'on anticipe à
les changements de transition du travail
certes on les subit on l'a vu d'ailleurs
dans l'industrie ont dit pourquoi on
s'est désindustrialisée on savait que
pendant dix ans et mes ailes et avoir de
nouveaux concurrents et c est donc en
effet on ne s'était pas forcément
préparé on le voit également dans les
services donc c'est vrai que c'est un
problème de formation donc certes vous
avez beaucoup de demandes mais dans vos
secteurs vous n'avez pas forcément à ces
personnes qui sont formés vous l'avez
dans l'apprentissage on est aussi en
france ou en effet l'apprentissage est
beaucoup moins développé par exemple
qu'en allemagne où vous avez un peu une
d'égalité des formations en allemagne
fait technique générale aucun problème
vous choisissez votre formation c'est
exactement les mêmes débouchés et vous
avez rapidement un emploi en france vous
avez différentes voies avec une virée
rares hiérarchie et des voix qui sont
beaucoup moins attractive et donc en
fait il n'y a pas de corrélation ce qui
explique que même si vous avez et bien
des demandes d'emploi ne l'est pas
forcément la demande qui va avec l'oncle
l'inadaptation de la formation à écouter
ce que ce qu'en dit le premier ministre
c'était à châtellerault le 27 septembre
dernier il annonce un plan justement
pour proposer une formation à tous les
chômeurs nous allons muscler le
dispositif de formation
et ouvrir ces nouveaux parcours à
l'ensemble des demandeurs d'emploi quel
que soit leur niveau de qualification y
compris pour les bacheliers
et au delà les chefs d'entreprise que
j'ai rencontrés m'ont dit t'es a besoin
de réactivité
ce qui suppose des formations
directement opérationnels entreprises
c'est l'un des principaux messages de ce
matin nous allons booster les formations
des demandeurs d'emploi mais veiller à
ce que la plupart d'entre elles se
déroulent à l'entreprise michel beaugas
ce plan de formation c'est une bonne
idée du gouvernement comment vous
comment vous l'accueillez coûté 1,8
former les demandeurs d'emploi pour
qu'il y ait une adéquation effectivement
entre l'emploi et et et le demandeur
d'emploi bien évidemment que c'est une
bonne idée sauf que ça fait 20 ans qu'on
forme les demandeurs d'emploi voilà et
c'est pas la formation qui fait l'emploi
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il faut bien
comprendre par exemple le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences le
fameux pic où on a formé deux millions
personnes c'était un million de
demandeurs d'emploi un million de jeunes
et bien seulement un quart de ces
personnes là sont en emploi aujourd'hui
donc il y à il ya aussi un autre
problème et puis là c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est la dares la problème de le
problème de formation ne vaut que pour
un tiers des emplois non pourvus pour la
motié de ces demandes n'ont pour lui
c'est quand même les conditions de
travail activités d'ubs et ils vont
parler de l'attractivité du salaire mais
quand même j'ai dû mal entendre ce que
vous dites là la formation c'est quand
même essentiel pour faire l'adéquation
formation et parce qu'on est trop de
temps en fait quand on découvre ça a été
dit on n'anticipe pas les les
entreprises globalement n'anticipe pas
parce que tant qu on al marché qu'on a
du travail en fait que le carnet de
commandes est plein et bien on a dans
les petites entreprises la tête dans le
guidon comme on dit donc on n'anticipe
pas al avance et donc quand on découvre
ton joint le temps de former les
demandeurs d'emploi ce besoin puisqu'ils
peuvent être de six mois un an voire
deux ans et bien en fait l'emploi y est
pourvue par quelque part d'autre
notamment par bien des travailleurs
détachés et c'est donc et l'emploi n'est
plus pour voir où le besoin n'existe
plus
françois bergerault la question de la
formation est ce que c'est majeur pour
vous je sais que c'est en pleine
réflexion sur voilà comment trouver une
solution voilà ces pénuries de main
d'oeuvre est ce que la formation ça fait
partie de la réflexion
alors oui bien évidemment la formation
et la base en fait il ya deux choses qui
sont très vrai c'est la formation et la
valorisation des secteurs et donc la
formation nous c'est tellement important
qu'en fait depuis maintenant trois ans
l'atelier des chefs a évolué pour
devenir un organisme de formation à tous
ces métiers dits en tension donc
aujourd'hui en forme à cette métier donc
la cuisine la pâtisserie la boulangerie
la petite enfance
l'assistante de vie aux familles la
coiffure et l'esthétique voiliers et
donc on pense en fait qu'il est
effectivement très important que les
gens puissent se former tout au long de
leur vie et nous on veut former que à
des métiers qui sont non délocalisables
c'est à dire que les métiers dont je
viens de vous parler ce sera quand même
très difficile de les avoir à l'autre
bout du monde et notre deuxième point de
vue c'est qu'en fait si on est dans
cette situation aujourd'hui sur ces
métiers là c'est qu'en fait pendant des
années ces métiers au était un tout
petit peu dévalorisés pour des mauvaises
raisons la première raison étant que à
l'école ans on disait qu'il fallait
absolument avoir son bac et que ce
qu'ils allaient faire autre chose
n'était pas des élèves brillants est ce
qu est une erreur c'est juste que voilà
il ya différents systèmes de cerveau et
donc il faut revaloriser ces métiers et
nous ce qu'on constate de façon très
intéressante aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a
en ce moment quatre cents élèves de
grandes écoles de commerce et
d'ingénieurs qui passe un ca paix avec
nous donc c'est des gens qui ont
vocation à diriger des entreprises mais
qui malgré tout ont compris qu'en fait
ces métiers là ces formations là elle
avait du sens et que dans leur vie
ailleurs servi
jean-christophe repos est ce que vous
formez vous même dans le reportage qu'on
a vu à rennes tout à l'heure on voyait
finalement le l'entreprise qui voit là
embaucher un demandeur d'emploi qui
avait vraiment aucune aucune compétence
de départ sur ce domaine particulier sur
ce métier particulier est-ce que vous
aussi dans des entreprises de taille
plus petite vous pouvez former les visas
m'arrive bien évidemment on est surtout
nous axé sur l'apprentissage sur le
l'artisanat on a vraiment un adn
apprentissage mais c'est vrai que c'est
un temps long apprentissage c'est de
trois ans donc ça ne tombe plus longue
pour répondre à une demande en rapide
c'est pas le mais c'est comme ça qu'ils
nous qui nous qui nous structure je
dirais dans l'artisanat est ça qui doit
donner aussi de l'attractivité des
métiers et on en parlait à apprendre de
venir sur le plateau
avec l'égalisation de coulisses
et c'était bien ce qu'on a dit non on
disait que vraiment c'est le problème de
l'orientation et de l'attractivité des
métiers l'attractivité des métiers n'est
pas que le salaire me semble-t-il est
aussi la capacité d'être en
reconnaissance de ce qu'on fait voilà on
vous citiez d'aider des gens qui avaient
fait un cursus universitaire moi même
avant de reprendre l'entreprise de mon
père j'ai fait un cheminement parce que
je n'étais pas très fier de devenir
électricien artisan électricien donc il
ya un moment où il faut que tu veux
qu'on a qu'on assume aussi le modèle
économique est la reconnaissance qu'on a
dans la société et il a été aussi
champion de rugby oui ils sont il savait
sagesse à l'horrible c'était autre chose
mais mais le fait est que on n'est pas
fiers de nos métiers comme dans fais un
métier qui est dite technique et dit
manuel et l'orientation est un élément
essentiel quand on nous pousse à aller
dans l'enseignement général au maximum
avec des débouchés et là on n'a pas le
les flux de déboucher ce que je
demandais comment comment dans l'ancien
mais en général on a derrière de
l'attractivité dans les métiers combien
on en a deux de bascule dans le dans
l'emploi géré on sait jamais for me
demandez jamais à l'éducation nationale
combien vous avez formé d'emplois sur
les diplômes quand on passe des diplômés
ses appuis on me demande maintenant
france compétences demande comment nos
communes emploi où je suis désolé mais
on n'a jamais demandé à une faculté
combien d'emplois vous avez créé par
contre combien vous avez de flux ça ça
marche pas mal donc nous on a besoin
d'avoir des gens qui sont plutôt
reconnaissante de revenir dans le métier
et avoir un métier dans les mains qui
leur permet de ne pas être
délocalisables on a fait beaucoup rire
les les politiques pendant des années
nos réunions disant nous on n'est pas de
délocaliser à bhl thème pour le pour le
coup le coc vide a bien prouvé que la
tpe de proximité à la fait le boulot
pendant pendant la crise elle était
présente à la fais le lien social elle a
fait de l'activité pendant la crise on a
fait de l'emploi et on a fait
l'apprentissage c'est quand même un truc
qui est fabuleux donc je pense que
l'après crise devrait continuer à
valoriser la structure mort pour moi
bâtiment mais tve surtout la petite
structure qui nous donne du sens du sens
à un projet de ville à l'apprentissage
par rapport aux chiffres que vous
donniez tout à l'heure c'est quand même
la tendance est à l'amélioration michel
garcia il ya eu un il ya eu une volonté
là aussi gouvernementale on peut sur
l'apprentissage et une volonté
gouvernementale
nous on avait soutenu aussi cette
démarche parce que effectivement ça
manquait les aides pendant la crise ils
ont été aussi pour beaucoup un pour
maintenir le nombre d'apprentis bien
évidemment parce qu'il ya quand même des
aides de l'état pour embaucher des
apprentis mais
ce que je regarde c'est le débouché est
effectivement l'apprentissage le
débouché en emploi il est important il a
plus de 62% ne me semble pas se le dise
progrès sur
la voie de garage les métiers manuels
techniques etc et puis à l'apprentissage
c'était on en avait une c'est un peu
la motié des apprentis sont dans le
supérieur donc c'est vrai ou c'est serré
sens où ça fait longtemps non non c'est
récent
modalités du temps qu'un changement
pourquoi il ya plusieurs choses beaucoup
de l'apprentissage notamment dans
l'industrie l'industrie c'est
complètement a complètement changé
puisqu'elle est complètement robotisée
donc aujourd'hui vous voulez plus des
gens qui sont sur les chaînes contre est
peut être qualification c'est plutôt des
opérateurs qui commandent des robots
donc c'est vrai que l'apprentissage sur
ce type de métier fait que en fait la
qualification et la valeur ajoutée va ne
cessé de croître donc forcément ça
attire plus parce que vous avez aussi
des salaires qui qui augmente par
rapport aussi est-ce qu'on vous disait
sur les universités l'attention il faut
aussi par tomber dans un travers en
disant voilà il me manque par exemple à
un mécanicien donc il faut absorber une
formation qui forment que des
mécaniciens ce que l'on voit par rapport
à l'étranger vous allez aux etats-unis
dans d'autres pays le but c'est de
former les gens mais aussi qu'ils aient
une manière de penser et d'être agile
pour pouvoir être adaptable et c'est en
ça que sert une formation vous avez en
allemagne vous pouvez apprendre à faire
de la mécanique et vous faites aussi de
la philosophie
se battre a dit ware ce n'est pas un
contrat de façon on n'avait pas le choix
vous devrez vous devrez mais ça fait pas
de 6 kg et le syndicaliste ça me fait
pas tiquer le syndicaliste à partir
longuement ou
l'adaptation est consentie et que
justement par exemple le le compte
personnel de formation peut servir à ça
aussi à s'adapter à augmenter en
qualifications et donc à aussi avoir un
meilleur salaire aussi les loges et
personne n'a juste par rapport à la
formation souvent comme on le pressent
les attentions on a eu par exemple une
pénurie dans tel domaine donc on va
former massivement que des gens dans ce
sens dans ce domaine là et ensuite la
personne reste dedans et n'est pas formé
en tout cas est ce que est ce que c'est
pas un jour donné par là dessus est ce
que c'est pas d'abord quand même la
demande pas d'avoir venir des secteurs
économiques et effectivement les
entreprises vont dire on a besoin de
formation dans tel ou tel domaine ça me
semble ça me semble évident il ya des
solutions qui existent et qu'il faudrait
développer encore plus que s'appelle la
fesse la cie que la formation en
situation de travail donc on ne peut
être formé dans l'entreprise mais c'est
d'une complexité on dirait un peu comme
la vae considérable dès qu'on peut faire
un truc il faut un dossier il faut le
valider il faut mais ça ce serait
laisser l'avenir quoi moi j'ai quelqu'un
de l'automobile qui veut travailler dans
le bâtiment il vient se former chez moi
et je le forme sur le sur ce site classé
du savoir-être la nation française pour
la paperasse abc complexité parler des
idées salaire mais vraiment je trouve
qu'il ya un grand absent la danse tout
le débat c'est pôle emploi quid de
l'efficacité et dans un pôle emploi
c'est bien le maillon intermédiaire
entre vous monsieur votre futur salarié
que ces pôles ans nous avons signé la
nation alors juste je finis quand on
écoute le patron de la confédération des
petites et moyennes entreprises il
demandait dans figaro il ya à peu près
un mois à pôle emploi de devenir le
directeur des ressources humaines pour
les tpe justement parce que pour
l'emploi est absent alors certainement
il n'y a pas assez d'agents mais quand
on regarde franchement comment
fonctionne pôle emploi sur le terrain
c'est parfois aberrants nous essayons
justement de trouver des solutions à ce
que on annonce beaucoup de chiffres
demandant des emplois et cetera dans le
bâtiment tandis qu'ana 230000 de
demandeurs d'emploi et nous on est
incapable de trouver un sur le terrain
donc on a demandé dans une convention
pour l'emploi de commandes on pouvait
voir ses listes les affiner regarder si
elles sont vraiment pour l'emploi et
comment on peut faire le point
territoire par territoire avec nos capeb
départementales pour trouver le band de
vendeurs d'emploi qui en capacité de
forme et surtout son site etc pour le
pour le moment pour le moment
sérieusement on a des relations des fois
un peu distendues dans les territoires
je vois que cette convention signée
nationale fait que chaque territoire
commence à signer des conventions alors
ça veut dire peut-être qu'on doit être
vraiment d'une politique de formation en
territoire enfin je le souhaite
fortement à pôle emploi est un bouc
émissaire facile parfois
les il y à il ya un manque de moyens
manifeste 1 et surtout il ya il ya un
manque d'accompagnement et des
demandeurs d'emploi et des entreprises
et donc il faut développer au sein de
pôle emploi c'est cesser ces deux formes
d'accompagnement
enfin
vous avec les conseillers ya plus on est
derrière un ordinateur alors c'est aussi
la moscovite mais on s'actualise et on
espère qu'on va nous envoyer une offre
d'emploi correspondante et quand on est
parfois journalistes en hollande on nous
propose des offres d'emploi de plombier
sais c'est pas un
petit pronostic man je ne cherche pas un
bouc émissaire pour la pénurie d'emploi
je sais a su trouver des solutions mon
but c'est que dans le territoire le chef
d'entreprise il trouve le salarié et que
ça marche mais quand je vois que des
plateformes met de ddd demande de podor
non emploi alors que normalement une
politique d'emploi qui tenus par prenant
pas je trouve que c est un paradoxe quoi
que ce soit une plateforme de mise en
relation qui fait de la vente de deux
vélos de voiture le bon coin pour le
bain et donc du coup et comment ça c'est
la solution avait bien verte et de la
jean christophe lebon il ya des il ya
des startups d'intérim qui sont créées
qui discret sur l'intérim 2.0 3.0 et 4.0
qui utilisent la date à des algorithmes
et qu'il faut c'est qu'ils font de chez
les offres
oui central
des secteurs c'est que c'est vrai que
les agents gèrent énormément de volume
d'offres et donc ils n'ont pas forcément
toujours le temps d'avoir la
connaissance sectorielle en se disant
voilà votre box appuyez-vous sur les
gens qui sautent sur le territoire dont
on a besoin allez donc c'est compliqué
on parle des salaires parce
qu'évidemment c'est l'une des questions
importantes pour
trouver une solution à cette pénurie de
demain des jeux vous propose entendre le
secrétaire général de la cgt s'étaient
le le 28 septembre dernier sur
boursorama il s'exprime aussi sur
boursorama philippe martinez la hausse
des salaires moi je veux prendre une
étude du ministère du travail ouais je
vais pas chercher mes sources que la cgt
qui dit le problème de ces emplois non
pourvus c'est l'attractivité ça tourne
autour de trois choses le salaire et
les conditions de travail les horaires
la flexibilité et puis l'exposition à
des produits dangereux et bah faut rayer
ces trois problèmes là et vous verrez
qu'on trouvera du monde alors moi on va
faire le focus sur les salaires françois
bergerault
l'umih a qui représente les métiers de
la restauration et de l'hôtellerie
proposent des hausses de salaires
jusqu'à 9% quand comment vous avez vous
accueilli cette cette proposition
en fait je peux je ne pense pas que ce
soit la solution quand c'est sur mon
mieux pour les salariés nous aujourd'hui
on est plutôt bien dix ans en termes de
salaires pourquoi parce qu'on a besoin
de moins salariés par lieu puisque nous
ce sont les gens qui font la cuisine ce
qu'on ait des cours de cuisine d'accord
donc on a moins restaurants
traditionnels et pourtant on a du mal à
trouver alors qu'on les paye mieux qu'un
restaurant traditionnel donc en fait
moins qu'on lui me dit + 9 % ce sera
toujours assez significativement en
dessous de ce que je propose mais en
fait il ya plein de choses et je pense
que
il ya un vrai problème qui est que on
n'a pas formé à ces demandes à une
époque aujourd'hui effectivement
les gens un peu plus de mal à travailler
à un moment où les autres s'amusent et
c'est le vrai paradoxe de la
restauration c'est que par définition
nous on travaille quasiment que quand
les gens s'arrêtent de travailler à
l'heure du déjeuner le soir et le week
end donc donc je pense que ça c'est un
vrai sujet et puis en revanche il ya un
qu'un vrai travail qu'on doit tous faire
qui est sur la revalorisation mais pas
que pécuniaire
la revalorisation de notre métier pour
montrer à quel point en fait c'est un
beau métier et ce n'est pas uniquement
être
corvéables et au service de en fait aux
services de est un est une très belle
notion en mai - seriez m'a dit voilà
quand même je suis pas au service de
cité au service mais en fait c'est
formidable d'être au service c'est pour
rendre les gens heureux et on se rend
compte qu'en fait on à dévaloriser ses
métiers donc je pense qu'il ya un vrai
travail là dessus au moins autant que
sur les salaires sur les salaires michel
beaugas force ouvrière se présente
souvent comme le le syndicat de la
feuille de paye en effet de fait donc
bon j'imagine que c'est quand même un
argument important pour ios reste ont
peut-être sur les métiers de la
restauration et de l'hôtellerie pour
répondre
ce que disais à l'instant françois
bergerault à écouter oui alors moi je
suis je suis d'accord avec lui il n'y a
pas que les salaires les salaires c'est
une part importante
bien évidemment d'autant plus quand on a
des horaires atypiques et il faut que
l'on soit bien bien rémunérés et mais
par contre il ya aussi les conditions de
travail c'est à dire que quand vous
travaillez du matin au soir avec des
coupures ou entre les entre deux
services et bien vous devez rentrer chez
vous et c'est et il n'y a pas vraiment
un temps de repos et il ya beaucoup de
salariés quatre heures dans leur voiture
voilà c'est ça elles doivent rentrer
donc il ya aussi ça donc il faut
organiser des roulements entre les repas
du midi et ceux qui travaillent le midi
peuvent peut-être ne pas travailler le
soir enfin il ya il ya des choses à
organiser qu on n'organisait pas jusqu'à
présent et je pense que là
enfin en tout cas du côté du patronat on
ans quand on en prend conscience mais le
salaire est quand même la source
principale puisque je rappelle que quand
même globalement c'est pas une preuve de
vie ce qui me conduit contredira c'est
que en france la croissance elle est
tirée par la consommation des ménages et
que donc
cesser de rentrer dans un cercle
vertueux que de d'augmenter les salaires
parce que plus on consomme plus on va
créer de l'emploi mais françois
bergerault je vous donne la parole tout
tout de suite françois bergerault moi
vous entends je me dis c'est presque les
fondamentaux de votre métier ou en tout
cas de l'organisation de votre métier
qu'il faut revoir
encore une fois typiquement sur
l'organisation du temps de travail chez
nous y'a pas de coupures chez nous il
n'ya pas de coupure donc ça veut dire
que les salariés de façon continue du
matin à l'après midi ou de l'après midi
au soir ça dépend quand est-ce qui
commence et il ne travaille que un
week-end sur deux ou sur trois donc
globalement pour le monde de la
restauration ils sont assez bien loti et
malgré tout on se rend compte qu'on a
quand même ce genre de ce genre de
problème de recrutement donc bien
évidemment qu'il ya les fondamentaux au
revoir mais mais nous on est vraiment un
cas atypique on est dans ce secteur de
la restauration avec plein de points qui
sont qui diffère de la restauration
restaurateurs si vous parlez au nom d
parlons de les tailleurs oui si vous oui
j'ai bien compris son leader mais si
vous parlez au nom des restaurateurs est
ce que vous n'avez pas le sentiment
quand même notamment sur les week-ends
alors je sais que dans les propositions
de l'umih a le choix c'est plutôt un
week-end par mois que week-end sur deux
un week-end par mois pour être en
famille voilà est-ce qu'il faut aller
plus loin qu'est ce que vous en pensez
françois bergerault
qu'ils faillent qu'il faille repenser
tout ça c'est certain puisque toute
façon un moment si on n'arrive pas à
avoir des salariés il faudra bien que
qu'on trouve une solution
le seul problème c'est que quand on
pense restaurant il ya des très grosses
maisons qui sont très profitables et
donc qu'ils peuvent peut-être se
permettre de doubler les effectifs etc
ou de rajouter un week end
mais globalement il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de restaurateurs qui ne roulent pas sur
l'or à la fin de la fin du mois et donc
quand on dit augmenter les salaires
quand on dit les faire travailler qu un
week-end sur deux week-ends surcroît
c'est bien gentil mais dont il faut
avoir quelqu'un d'autre et donc à un
moment comment vont faire les petits
restaurateurs effectivement on est dans
le principe de réalité anne-sophie lcif
puis on compare le salaire mais ça va au
delà il peut aussi avoir une logique
d'intéressement des salariés par exemple
ça c'est un levier qu'on pourrait
activer et puis on peut regarder ce qui
se passe justement outre manche où il ya
de l'inflation et pourquoi ya de
l'inflation parce qu'il ya une hausse
générale des salaires ce qu'on n'a pas
en effet en france à part dans certains
secteurs c'est vrai que là on pose ces
questions est ce qu'il faut augmenter
les salaires en fait on est juste revenu
dans ce qu'est l'économie d'offres et
demandes et quand vous n'avez pas en
effet assez d'offres par rapport à la
demande eh bien vous avez un mécanisme
d'ajustement au niveau des prix c'est
assez basique jeu comment souvent
l'oubli mais on est vraiment dans cet
aspect là et aux états unis en effet
dans les secteurs notamment de la
restauration il ya aussi des énormes
pénurie vous pouvez aller jusqu'à 10%
d'augmentation de salaire alors qu'on
n'est pas dans un pays qui est quand
même très très social malgré sur
l'intéressement sur surfer alors juste
le relief le partage de la richesse
n'a pas laissé pas il n'y a pas que des
grandes chaînes ya vraiment l'idée de
faire participer le salarié en ayant de
l'intérieur de l'intéressement en ayant
des parts dans l'entreprise en étant
intéressé aux bénéfices vous avez
énormément de choses alors c'est vrai
que outre atlantique c'est des économies
qui sont beaucoup plus capitalistiques
on peut aussi avoir des actions toutes
sortes de produits mais en tout cas ça
se développe et une dernière chose qu'il
faut se dire c'est que ces emplois c'est
des emplois qui peuvent directement être
en concurrence à devenir indépendant
c'est des secteurs vous pouvez beaucoup
plus se demander c'est quoi mon avantage
de travailler pour quelqu'un c'est quoi
mon avantage d'être auto entrepreneur
est donc de choisir est justement de
modérer ces conditions donc ça va de
plus en plus se poser pour ces
secteurs-là en fait pour pour les
patrons jean-christophe pour augmenter
les salaires ou au mieux répartir la
richesse est ce que ça vous semble à la
dimension des entreprises que vous
représentez possible tout à fait puisque
nous on a toujours temps des gestions de
salaires qui sont en régionale donc pas
territoire par territoire c'est négociés
paritairement avec les organisations de
salariés pour trouver le juste modèle
économique du territoire ça correspond
aussi quand même à l'abri richesses du
territoire on ne peut pas avoir des
salaires sur paris comme on peut les
avoir je dirais dans la creuse et c'est
donc ça correspond au marché moi je dis
qu'il faut plutôt arriver à trouver et
dans l'atp on n'a pas le patron qui
vienne 10 fois le salaire de son salarié
je peux me permettre au niveau de
partage de richesse par l'atp notre but
étant de bien vivre en tant
qu'entrepreneur et puisque nous sommes
des entrepreneurs mais le but quand vous
regardez
une des peu de plomberie le patron qui a
quatre salariés ne gagne pas 10 fois le
salaire de 100 200 salariés donc du coup
nous on est pour bien su répartir les
richesses et nous c'est vraiment un
projet de vie commune c'est qu'on
voudrait offrir dans la tpe du bâtiment
c'est à dire une entreprise à taille
humaine de proximité
en ruralité qui correspond vraiment à ce
que les français ont vécu dans la
période qu'ovide dans la partie je me
réinvente un jour mais redimensionné je
vois comment je vis mieux ma qualité de
vie oui michel beaugas oui sur
l'intéressement et c'est
un grand point de vigilance et c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de cotisations sociales
sur l'intéressement et sur la
participation et attention on a quand
même un système social qui est
performant malgré ce qu'on veut dire est
que ces cotisations viennent abonder les
caisses de sécurité sociale et sert
qu'aux états unis par exemple que ça
n'existe pas voilà donc il faut il faut
qu'on soit prudent
le salaire pour moi est la meilleure des
garanties d'avoir un système social
effectif un partage votre point de vue
puisque nous sommes pas très favorable
au micro social qui est une
précarisation telle avait perdu la micro
social c'est que le miel à la
micro-entreprise quoi l'auto
entrepreneur si vous voulez la mineure
le régime fiscal qui fait qu'en fait on
crée de la précarité de la capeb a été
créée après guerre parce qu'on avait des
tâcherons qui étaient corvéables
malléable et qui était à la merci de
deux grands groupes qui demandait de la
main d'oeuvre pas chère le micro social
ressemble très très lentement à ça et
détruit le régime social géré détruits
l'apprentissage enfin ne participent pas
ou en tout cas ne discute pas mais ne
participe pas majoritairement donc la
création d'entreprise c'est bien mais la
création d'entreprise à moyen terme avec
la richesse c'est pour ça qu'on me
demandait nous que ce micro social que
c'est au tour de riner soit limité dans
le temps en activité principale tient il
nous reste un peu plus de 8 ya une
question que je voulais vous poser j'ai
oublié de la poser sur le pont pour
illustrer le décalage entre entre les
offres non pourvues et c est ce que le
travail au noir est une partie de
l'explication ou est-ce que je suis à
côté de la plaque alors comme son nom
l'indiqué c'est difficile de le
quantifier fils que voilà alors bien
évidemment c'est sûr que ça peut jouer
surtout pendant le coc vie de ces sûr
d'avoir ce genre ce genre d'activité
alors après ça dépend beaucoup des
secteurs où la mini les secteurs sont
quand même beaucoup plus impacté que
d'autres en tant que c'est sûr que ça
joue mais comme vous le dites très bien
ça reste quand même ponctuelle et puis
vous avez pas voilà vos droits à la
retraite est tout autre et le bâtiment
oui parce que le coût de la vie quand on
doit faire appel à un entrepreneur qu'on
fait un devis on l'a tous fait on
regarde ce que nous donne l'entreprise
et tout le monde à quelqu'un qui connaît
quelqu'un qui est comparé les prix il
n'y a pas photo il ya un gros souci avec
très très vite vous parlez donc de
contourner quoi social mais c'est vrai
que l'on voit et qu'on verra de plus en
plus devant le stand à la rénovation à
80 sont écologiques le risque des
plateformes et ce qui se passe pour tous
les services et que vous aurez de plus
en plus de plateformes et on le voit aux
états unis qui ont souvent en avance
là-dessus on demandera en effet un
salarié dans votre domaine pendant une
heure tel jour payer tant aimé ce sera
l'offre et la demande par rapport à
oignies le retour des tâcherons merci
beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce débat
ici et en visioconférence c'était
c'était vraiment très intéressant je
vais remercier toutes les équipes de de
public sénat et plus particulièrement
celle de sens public isabelle pain sec
et rédactrice en chef mode fauvel et
lucie span l'air la programmation et
notre stagiaire benjamin orlandini qui
étaient fabriqués rentrer chez lui fait
le meilleur